so say you have two entrepreneurs that
begin at the same exact time in the same
exact industry two of them right
they start growing their businesses if
you notice they're growing at the same
time
but then there comes the wall that they
had the obstacle that they had noticed
the first one
has a massive drop off the second one
doesn't and it goes bigger and the
distance between them gets wider and
wider and wider so why is that
it's because one of them knew how to
handle the obstacle they face when they
hit a wall
the other one didn't today we're going
to talk about nine obstacles you will
face as an entrepreneur
[Music]
so make sure to stick around to the very
end because i'm going to give you a pdf
on today's message so let's get right
into it number one
creativity when your business starts
growing and you get to a point there
where you become stale
everything's the same you're no longer
growing sometimes like why are we not
growing
one of the factors could be there's no
more creative innovative campaigns
creative strategies
next marketing campaign that comes out
it's just business
as usual and when there's lack of
creativity there's boredom when there's
board and people start looking all over
the place
you lose customers you lose employees
you lose agents you lose sales people so
you got to get creative
second option you're going to face is
resources as far as money now
what do you mean by the obstacle i'm
gonna face is money
look at the two guys or the two gals
that are going as entrepreneurs
when you hit a wall one has the money
to invest back into the business in an
area to help
accelerate or solve the problem the
other one's been spending all the money
or taking too much income out
they don't have it they lose momentum
resources
is another obstacle you're going to face
and many different things you may have
an opportunity to buy technology you may
have an opportunity to expand and get a
new c-suite executive
that's going to bring the set of talents
and skill that's going to grow your
company
but if you've been spending too much
money you don't have that 200 000
to pay that c-suite executive that is
resources so so far we've talked about
creativity and resources now let's talk
about the other obstacle you can
overcome
which is talent what is talent i was
reading a book by patty mccourt called i
believe it's called
powerful i think it's called powerful
and i was reading this book and
one side she worked for netflix for 14
years and she was pretty much their
chief hr and one day one of the
departments comes up
and says hey i want to recruit 50
employees at 50 000
because i need that support for my
department she says why 50 at 50 000.
she says that's because that's what i
need and patty says what makes you think
is 50 at 50 000.
maybe it's 25 out of 100 000
maybe it's 10 at 250 why 50 at 50
and the guy started thinking about
saying huh it's not like you're saying
no to two and a half million dollar
budget
you're just saying maybe it's not 50 at
50. so you're thinking about it
as the company grew and i was building
first like let's just get anybody here
help us out maybe 15 bucks an hour
and i can afford to pay somebody 50k eur
maybe 75k
maybe 100k but as you get bigger
the talent you need here is not going to
be able to handle it here
and the talent you have here may be good
enough but may not be good enough here
you have to constantly be increasing
your talent pool
if you don't increase your talent pool
you don't know the talent here
may want to stay at this level so you
may want to have to get somebody else
that wants to grow the company to this
level
but if you stick with that same exact
talent they were good for this company
size at a million or 5 million or 10
million euro
but maybe you're not good at 50 million
a year 100 million a year
a billion year you have to assess that
obstacle you can say
how come this guy doesn't want it that
bad how come you don't want to grow
maybe they just don't
maybe they're just happy where they are
what are you going to do you got to go
and find better talent that wants to
take you to the next level
and maybe those folks will have a
position in the company just not at an
executive level or senior executive
level
with the company next one is contacts
and i want to make sure you look at
contacts the same way as we did with
talent watch this
the talent pool here may have been good
for this size of a business
but not this size so you either have to
challenge them to see if they want to
upgrade
or you have to go recruit somebody else
to help you get here right same with
contact
your existing contacts that you have in
your rolodex may have been good
for here but maybe to get to this level
you need to kind of go and add some new
people to your rolodex
maybe to get to this level you got to go
business and add some new people to that
rolodex so how do you do
what do you do the other night i was
sitting out with a group of guys and
they were saying pat
what's been your main focus lately i
said all i'm doing
from morning till night i am recruiting
executives to two companies one is my
insurance company
one is valuetainment all i'm doing is on
the phone with people recruiting it
doesn't matter what i'm doing
it's all about recruiting so i'm using
my data pool that i have of the contacts
and i'm reaching out to them who do you
know who do you know who do you know who
do you know who do you know
and i'm getting higher quality names for
my recruiting why
because there's no way in the world i
can get to the next level with the
existing talent that i have okay
very few of them will recreate
themselves constantly
not everybody will so the next challenge
was going to be context now the fifth
one is vision vision is on you sometimes
you as the leader you're going i was on
a board called the other day with a
group of uh
insurance executives that were all doing
20 plus million per year 20 to 100
million
they're doing good for themselves
they're doing very good for themselves
and we were being challenged on a lofty
goal on what to do with the slofty goal
right
and everybody goes giving their ideas
and i go at the end i say listen one of
the challenges we're all going to face
is the following sometimes when you're
making 5 million a year or 10 million a
year you're netting two and a half
million a year
you go to the right country clubs you go
to the right restaurants you have the
caviar you have the lobster you have the
sushi you have the sea urchin
you have the car you have the clothes
you have the tailor you have all that
stuff that you got going on right
part of the club's part of the sport
team's part of all that stuff who's
whose parties you go to
sometimes you lose the vision and you
lose the motivation
and sometimes you're not motivating
anymore you sound like the same person
10 years ago and it's the same exact
thing i
as a person working for you or i'm one
of the people on your team
like where is this guy's fire i bought
into your fire 10 years ago
i bought into your fire five years ago i
bought into your fire year ago
where is that fire where is that person
i chose to want to run with and work
with what happened to that person's fire
if you don't snap out of it and figure
out a way to get your vision back on to
the next level
you're not going to stay at the same
level you are there's always going to be
a dip because
your talent pool that you have with your
company is going to say like i want to
run with somebody that's got a big
vision
and you seem to be very content where
you're at and then i start looking
elsewhere right sometimes a setback is
because your vision has been already
filled
you got a full stomach you're no longer
thinking big enough you start facing a
big obstacle and this one by the way can
be very annoying if you ever go through
this next
tech so what's tech speed to me when i
see tech i see speed
i just see those two together i see tech
speed and efficiency together all the
time right
so myself four years ago three years ago
i built my business on a software that
when i first started doing business with
this gentleman 11 12 years ago
he told me this software is built for
business this size so one day three
years ago him and i are talking
and he says to me pat i got some bad
news for you says what's that
i said buddy my software is not built
for a big company the way you're going
right now
i can't sustain that i said if you go
with me for a while i'm about to break
i'm just telling you i can't sustain you
for too long think about
he is telling a customer we're very good
friends
he's saying you've outgrown me i can't
even get my servers i can't get nothing
to support you
i'm just telling you you got to do
something about it so what do i do i
look and i said okay my tech i got a big
tech issue
if that tech breaks apart i got a big
setback not a small one
a very big one what does that cost to me
is it a million dollar cost
is it a two million dollar cost is it a
three million dollar cost by the way is
it a 10 million dollar setback
is it a 100 million dollar setback is it
a quarter billion dollar setback
if that tech was to fall apart to me
it's somewhere around a quarter of a
billion
to a half a billion dollar mistake if
the software was to break apart so what
do we do
immediately meeting get everybody in
technology engineers start pitching
their products who can do it better
we go through eight weeks of the whole
findings and
you know the sticky pads on the con
conference room every week in our
conference room we have two 300 new
sticky pads
next week two three hundred sticky pads
every single week for eight weeks
then we come out with a work order like
this big and then we go around and see
how much it's gonna cost the number came
around three to five million dollars
our man hours their man hours engineers
everybody we built the software why
i was about to face a massive obstacle
if i wasn't going to get the tech now
watch this i could have been stubborn
and said oh
it's going to be okay nope it worked for
this side mr bed david
it maybe will work for this size but
it's going to break at this side so what
do you want to do you have the resources
we had the resources we had the right
people we went and hired them
next thing you know the software was
launched five months ago
last one in the month of march
record-breaking month why
because the software now works so fast
versus what we had in the back
in the past next enemy political as you
get bigger
you will have new enemies every time you
get bigger it's newer enemies if you
think about it right now
i actually want you to go back and think
about it go back five years ago who was
your number one enemy in business
go back five years ago think about your
number one enemy matter if i go back
three years ago
who was your number one enemy who did
you go to sleep in 2018
thinking about your enemy go to 2017 how
about 2016 how about 2015
how about 2011 do you see how you go
back do you even think about that enemy
today
if you've been growing and you've been
developing yourself
that person or business or individual
should not be your enemy today
you must graduate enemies but as you
graduate enemies
new enemies show up some are political
some is government
some is attorneys some is another person
you're going up against
some is a market share somewhat your
business you're going to face that you
cannot eliminate that that's just going
to be happening the only way you
eliminate
an enemy that you're going up against is
to stay small
stay very small in a community the
smaller you are the fewer enemies you
have
but you're going to face that so how do
you handle that is it going head-on
is it trying to collaborate are they
trying to bully you around you have to
kind of stand up to yourself sometimes
do you start creating and poking if you
poke too much you make poke back
so maybe you don't poke you just kind of
stay focused on your business and you
try to get the right people to make
these things
work out this is all the different
challenges you will face also with your
enemies
at every level i've grown i've had
enemies every level i've grown
ninety percent of the time i've
befriended my enemies
we have figured out a way to make it
work and those ten percent that we
didn't we just couldn't do it we had to
go head on there's nothing we could do
about it
until eventually you graduate and
someone will stick around for a very
very long time
and some of them will pretty much go
away and say you know what i don't want
to compete with you directly i want to
go this way or you say i don't want to
compete with you directly this is my
market
this is your market we don't even have
to compete against each other we go two
separate ways but you're going to be
facing this unfortunately
most entrepreneurs and business owners
do not know how to handle this
and this gets a lot of people to go out
of business now eight
culture you're growing your business
things are going good
all of a sudden you're like man how come
we are we are flattened out
what's going on here what is it you
can't figure it out
i can't even feel it anymore what's
going on people are not excited anymore
what happened to this company
well your culture either there is no
culture
either the culture used to be a nice
culture to be around but the culture's
gotten boring
maybe you're not around anymore you've
given up the culture to somebody else
and they don't know how to continue the
culture that you create at the beginning
of the company
so this culture is not helping you
attract the new talent the right
talent this culture is not getting the
right people to want to come work with
you
this culture is not allowing you to
raise more money this culture is not
creating a place where it's very
creative wide
you got to go back and ask the culture
you're responsible for it if you're the
entrepreneur and last but not least
reputation
i had issues when i was small as i got
bigger i still had issues
and i got bigger i still had issues this
is never going away
today especially anybody and everybody
can say
anything they want about you how do you
handle that years ago when i started
creating content
eight years ago the number one reason
why i created content the number one
reason why i created content
wasn't because i wanted to be a youtuber
wasn't because i wanted to make money
off of you it wasn't because
we were it was simply because if you and
i were gonna do business together
i wanted you to say huh let me see this
guy here what is this guy i go on
youtube patrick
david let me look why i like what he
says how interesting
i actually like what he stands for i
like the way he does interviews
i like the way he talks about business i
like his values and principles
we match together you know what i want
to do business with them or you'd go
looking and say
i just don't like this guy he's too much
about capitalism
he's all about entrepreneurship i don't
like him i don't want to ever do
business with this guy
no problem but it became a filtering
process you know what's the one rule
about this
i'll give you a few challenges okay one
time we had a customer very interesting
story
we're year-round in the business i start
doing what i'm doing this one guy all of
a sudden i notice everywhere he's
commenting
he's commenting this is commenting
that's coming to this okay and then
one day i'm like i'm just gonna call
this guy so i'm like hey give me his
number tikrun tikka and get some i might
call him up
say hey john how you doing good who's
this patrick david patrick
david yeah patrick david i said look did
we do something sounds like you're upset
with me or somebody
tell me what i did to upset you because
i'm curious
and he says well let me tell you
something all you think about is
capitalism
money doesn't rule the world it's not
all about money it's about this i said
okay
so tell me what you believe in he says i
believe in communism i said you believe
in communism yeah i said great
i was raised by a communist what do you
like about communism we had a 45 minute
conversation together okay you know what
happened after the 45 minute
he said you know what pat i said what's
that he says i had a different idea who
you were
i appreciate you calling me just the
fact that you heard me out
i appreciate that we had a good banter
together i said yeah no no problem cool
here's my number if you want to keep in
contact with me i'm just glad i had a
conversation with you
i thought something really happened
where you were upset where apparently
what up such is the fact that i believe
in capitalism yeah
look i got my philosophies you got
chores i think what good thing that
happened came out of this is we had a
good banter yeah absolutely ha ha we got
off the phone
seven years later he got called to me we
had a good conversation remember seven
years ago when i called you yeah
i'm an entrepreneur now right i mean the
whole story with live changes what's the
point
one phone call one phone call we had an
issue where the phone call wasn't made
it dragged that for 12 months just
because of one
simple phone call i had a call yesterday
with one of my guys we're having a
conflict with this person here
with this customer here i said when did
the conflict start
two weeks ago i said when did you reach
out to the customer
we haven't yet i said you've had a
conflict with a customer you haven't
reached no we're thinking about reaching
out on monday
so what are you talking about on monday
call the customer today
right now like when the conflict happens
call the customer
ask him hey mary john sounds like i did
something that upsets you can you please
help me know what it is because i don't
know you know what upset me what upset
me is the fact that
perfect you know what i am so sorry i
wish i knew this
it's totally my fault i apologize i'm
going to work on this area
aside from this did i do anything else
that upset you
no nothing this was it well i'm glad to
know how about this john and mary what
if i work on this area and i'm able to
follow up with you to provide you with
abc
are you good with moving forward doing
business together yeah sure i just want
to let you know everybody i've ever done
business with
we've always had some kind of a
differences at one point there's always
been a conflict with my marriage with my
best friends my business partners
but once we're able to overcome that and
move forward
that ends up become one of the best
relationships i have i'm open to it if
you are you know what patrick
we like your approach we're open to it
wonderful if you need to get a hold of
me john and mary
this is my phone number is it is it okay
for me to call john
call bobby for them to continue the
process absolutely
thank you again if you need anything
call me i'm gonna call bobby bobby
should call you next 30 minutes
excellent right i call bobby bobby i
just spoke to him for 45 minutes call
john and mary
half the battle with reputation as
credibility is
instant follow-up to address the issue
you have to know that you can't please
everybody
you cannot please everybody i'm in the
insurance industry
i can't please the fact that only 10 of
people pass their license
i can't please everybody that this is
not an easy industry to be a part of
but i can do enough for the market to
say
i actually like doing business with this
person again the bigger you get
the more this is going to be the smaller
you are the smaller this is
the bigger you get the more resources
you need the bigger you get the more
creative you need to get on the inside
the bigger you get the better talent you
need the bigger you get the stronger
contacts you need the bigger you get the
bigger the vision needs to be the
clearer needs to be
the bigger you get the better tech
you're gonna need the bigger you get the
better you'll need to be with enemies
the bigger you get the more your culture
is gonna matter to have a higher
retention and the bigger you get the
better you need to get
at dealing with people who don't like
the way you do business
because your credibility is on the line
and your reputations are on the line so
having said that
these were the nine obstacles you're
gonna overcome as an entrepreneur if you
want today's message
in pdf text huh uh
let's say reputation it's a tough war
text reputation
to three one zero three four zero one
one three two once again text award
reputation you see it on the screen to
three one zero
three four zero one one three two and if
you're not in the us you can go in the
description below subscribe to our
newsletter we'll send you today's pdf
and if you enjoyed today's video that i
talked about nine obstacles to overcome
as an entrepreneur i did a video a few
years ago
titled how to improve your work ethic if
you've never seen the video
how to improve your work ethic this was
probably four or five years ago
it's one of my favorite videos i ever
put up it's a very important topic click
over here to go watch that video
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye
[Music]